[GRAND MUSIC]
[BELLS CHIMING, FOOTSTEPS]
[ROCK MUSIC]
[? Bobby, ?] This state is
fortunate to have you here.
This university is
I look forward to working
with you as U of A
continues to demonstrate
what it means
to be a world class university.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHORAL MUSIC]
As an institution of
higher learning, discovery,
and service, it is critical
that we remain a community that
accepts and encourages a
diversity of thought, heritage,
and tradition.
We must continue to be
a place that encourages
an open exchange of ideas.
As a public
university, our campus
is a public space, open
to all people of Arizona,
where we must
support and respect
the constitutional rights of
students, visitors, faculty,
and staff.
Bear down, and go, cats.